hey guys I'm Eric Vance and guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 featured a new promo
spot during the Superbowl with a ton of
new footage and it's all mixed in with
stuff that we've seen in past trailers
which I've already broken down into
other videos but let's take a look at
all the new stuff and talk about
everything that we've learned about the
story possible spoilers ahead here we go
[Music]
in the hell do you think you are cool a
lot of stuff here but let's start with
this rare purple backdrop behind the
Marvel logo it looks like this movie is
doubling down on the Guardians having
the most colorful palette of the MCU
honestly while James Gunn seems to be
saving the major plot stuff and Easter
eggs for the movie he gets that by
showing us an exciting funny color
packed trailer that actually looks and
feels like a comic book is really all we
need that said this shade of purple may
be connected to the purple infinity
stone in the guardians movies the Power
Stone which we saw in the first one or
it could just be a coincidence
and speaking of bright color we get
these new shots of Aisha and the
sovereign all covered in gold the
sovereign are a superior arrogant race
of beings that have hired the Guardians
to take down this interdimensional
monster that's feeding on their power
source but it sounds like Aisha will be
one of the villains in this movie so I'm
guessing that the guardians are going to
screw her over somehow and she's going
to want revenge now I've mentioned it
before but in the comics Aisha is
another name for kismet who is a
genetically perfect super being designed
by a group of scientists called The
Enclave to be a female counterpart to
Adam warlock but I'm not sure if that
backstory is coming into this movie we
also see this quick shot of Drax
sticking this superhero landing in a
location that we've seen in past
trailers but if you look closely the
background say that had some coral
colored organic matter and I'll talk
about that more of it later also we know
that yondu is joining the guardians in
this movie and we see him and quill
piloting the ship now the editing makes
it look like it's the Milano in the
space battle sequence but quills clothes
are different here and the cockpit looks
totally different so I'm thinking this
is a Ravager ship maybe a new one called
the quadrant that's rumored to be in
this movie let's move on
[Applause]
was awesome
ah
okay in case we were wondering the music
throughout this whole trailer is a
version of Fleetwood Mac's the chain
it's from their classic album rumours
recorded while the band mates marriages
with each other we're falling apart and
the lyrics are all about keeping a
relationship together even though you
may hate each other and that could be
hinting that the embattled sister
relationship between Gomorrah and nebula
also people like John do and Rockets
don't really feel comfortable as part of
the Guardians team or it could be
reflecting quills relationship with his
father ego the Living Planet a super
being that takes the form of a whole
planet but also created a human form
played by Kurt Russell and I think this
trailer actually gives us our first look
at Eagles planetary form quill and
rocket are jumping out towards something
that looks similar to the background
behind Drax earlier now what is this
thing I speculated before that this
whole location could be the core of ego
and this organic looking object looks
like kind of a giant organ like a brain
or a heart with nerve strands or maybe
Dame's attached to it so we'll see if
this theory ends up being right but I'm
feeling better and better about it with
each new trailer that comes out also I
love this massive gun that Gamora uses
here it seems like one of Rockets guns I
just can't see how this thing is even
practical like I feel like the most
damage it's going to do is tear own
shoulders and lower back now this shot
of John do and rocket has been updated
with new cgi since the earlier trailers
like we can see baby Groot on his
shoulder now
and his Yaka arrow whizzing through all
these Ravagers ending with him catching
it just like he did in the first movie
but if you look closely as yondu's
Mohawk Finn has been enhanced I think
this whole sequence with these three is
going to be the best part of the movie
like James Gunn seems super proud of it
based on how much of it we're seeing in
these trailers now before we were
wondering why yondu is parting ways with
the Ravagers and it seems like they're
going to mutiny against him remember
that shot at the end of the first film
when yondu realizes quilt rolls him by
swapping out the power stone yondu
smiles he still has a bit of a soft spot
for quill but that also seems like the
kind of thing that would piss off all
the other Ravagers so in this movie I
think they're going to turn on him for
going stop let's move on
oh good what's that he says welcome to
the frickin guardians of the galaxy okay
cool let's get into this section this
trailer shows us more of the new members
of the team mantis and nebula mantis
comes in the story with ego and
according to James Gunn she's had
limited contact with other beings giving
her this childlike sense of wonder now
this is the first we've seen of nebula
since the first teaser and if you read
look at that shot she appeared to be a
prisoner in a location looks very
similar to where we saw the sovereign so
I'm thinking that she is going to join
the guardians very early in the movie
like she's part of their deal to defeat
the obelisk monster but I'm guessing
things don't go exactly as planned
because we're going to see some more
conflict between these sisters you can
see Gamora briefly in the frame during
this close-up fight and nebula appears
to be the one gunning down Gamora in the
shot that we saw in the last trailer now
I enjoyed this welcome to the freakin
guardians of the galaxy moment he says
welcome to the frickin guardians of the
galaxy but as Rocket says in the next
part holy he didn't use frickin I don't
think it's going to be frickin in the
movie either like that would be a super
easy audio swap but I get it you can't
swear during the Super Bowl kids don't
read Bill Belichick slip okay let's look
at this final section
only he didn't use fricken look out oh
wow I tried - okay so in this section we
see the other villain in this movie
taser face he's one of yondu's Ravagers
who leads the mutiny against them now I
know Aisha and taser face chasing down
the Guardians doesn't seem like super
high stakes but that's what James Gunn
wanted with this movie his goal was for
it to be smaller and more self-contained
and more focused on the characters
without the whole universe being
threatened like in the first guardians
and so many other MCU movies so all the
stuff with the Infinity stones and
Thanos won't be in this movie
it sounds like Marvel is saving a lot of
that stuff for the infinity war movies
which if they're really going to include
all of these characters plus everyone
from civil war and all the other MCU
films infinity war is going to be
insanely massive the whole second movie
is probably just going to be a 2-hour
version of that long take in the
Avengers with the camera gliding across
like 40 superheroes as they each do
their own cool move like I feel like
that's all they're gonna have time for
it now I like baby Groot that's the
little head shake here to confirm that
he didn't say fricken holy he didn't use
fricken now I have a feeling that this
was composed surely for the trailer and
promotional footage like maybe we won't
see this in actual movie like I love
this gag of mantas getting wiped out by
flaming debris
it's probably the funniest part of any
of the trailers but this just doesn't
seem like something that would happen in
the movie right like that Rock probably
would have killed mantis or at least
really hurt her
and everyone just kind of shrugs it off
like look out oh my god you killed
mantis yeah now I could be wrong but I
think it's more in character for James
gun to shoot a joke just for promotional
stuff than to actually make it part of
the film I don't know we'll see okay
that's everything let me know what you
thought about this Super Bowl spot in
the comments hopefully we'll get another
trailer that gives us more info about
Kurt Russell's version of ego but until
then make sure to check out my last two
breakdowns of trailers regarding the
galaxy vol 2 and if you liked this video
please hit like and subscribe to new
rockstars and if you really like us you
can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current patrons
especially Kelly hopper you can hit me
up on Twitter at EA box with any
thoughts that theories you have about
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 or follow
new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars for info for when our videos
are coming out alright thanks for
watching bye
[Music]